[Music]
just before we went on the uh air
tonight just before we we started my
producer uh came up to me and he said
that you had a true story you want to
tell this is this is completely 100 true
true story and uh that it involves the
fact that you've been comforting a
friend very recently here in los angeles
yeah my girlfriend um uh has been going
through this really bizarre horrific
ordeal which is um i think it was like
what like two weeks ago or something
i don't you read about this story but
there was got a lot of attention this
story yeah there was a there was like a
head and limbs found in runyon canyon
near the hollywood near the hollywood
sign i said
yeah near the hollywood sign yeah
it did sound like that was going
delicious i like heads yeah
no but yes it was a uh obviously a a a a
a dismembered head yes and and and uh i
believe uh hands yeah um and you're the
hollywood yeah discovered by a dog it
was my friend's dog
i heard that i heard that a dog
discovered and then this turns out to be
your friend's dog my friend i got into
work and willarnette said you know that
you know that head like just like i'm
telling you like you know that head they
found they said he goes it was aaron's
dog what
we could not believe it he was on a walk
with his dog walker my friend
which was in the news yeah his name is
ollie
he is a golden retriever
and um and he likes balls like like
socks soccer balls
he's a family show
and um and i think he's he's a digger
and so he was digging and he came out
like all proud with this bag and
something fell out and it was the head
guys this is your friend this is my
friend's dog
i'm not kidding you they questioned the
dog walker and they kept the dog for
like four hours well here's the crazy
thing is your friend the police uh had
your dog get into the squad car and and
and the dog was sort of traumatized by
what happened and your friend took a
photograph
of the dog in the back of the squad car
and i saw the photograph and he he looks
like he is freaked out that he just
found a human head
look at this yeah look at that
[Laughter]
look at this
oh man that is the exact that is the
look
the gloves was like
i didn't know i didn't know
i just thought it was a soccer ball and
that's ollie the dog that's ollie oh my
god
that's incredible well we broke he's
always really been through some [ __ ]
yeah um by the way he is uh
nominated for an aspca award he wasn't
given one yet
they nominated for finding this body
they nominated meaning he's gotta wait
to see if somebody else came up with
something better than finding a head
yeah
but you know what we know what face he's
gonna make the night he loses that's for
sure
and the winner is
not ollie